one other little note on Herschel Walker
we continue talking about Herschel
Walker the Georgia Republican Senate
candidate and his fake badge
um I have sort of like good news and bad
news I guess the good news at this point
is that it's really pretty transparent
that his badge is fake this goes back to
his debate with Rafael Warnock Rafael
Warnock correctly accused Herschel
Walker of lying about being a law
enforcement officer at which point
Herschel Walker took out a badge during
the debate now it certainly could be a
badge that was handed to him by some
sheriff and he claims that it is but it
is meaningless it confers no law
enforcement power
um Herschel Walker has not been and is
not today any kind of law enforcement
officer authorized to do anything at all
well Herschel Walker did another one of
these campaign events yesterday and at
this one he said that when you laugh at
his badge you're laughing at the
military and you're laughing at law
enforcement that doesn't make any sense
Herschel but here he is saying it
I love my
love when they laugh at my fans they
laugh at every military every police
officer in the country how why that
doesn't make sense Herschel they because
they're the one who gave me the bad
cause I support them they support
me so what we got to do is tell them if
they don't like our police leave go
somewhere else we're not holding you
here it's not that we don't like the
police you are not a police officer
think about this unhinged word salad
this country
he seems completely disoriented
if you laugh at his fake badge which
confers no law enforcement Authority
whatsoever
you're laughing at our military and
you're laughing at our law enforcement
and then he says if you don't like our
law enforcement just leave
nobody's talking about how his fake
badge connects to any particular view
about the police
he is not a police officer it has
nothing to do with liking or disliking
liking police officers we're not even
really laughing like we sort of are I
mean it's cartoonish and funny in a way
but we're finding it sickening and very
sad but you know what truly the saddest
part of all of this is I I it's
embarrassing to even mention this
the race is even closer now than it was
before the badge Fiasco before the
abortion and badge Fiasco Raphael
Warnock was winning by nearly three by
nearly four points warnock's lead is now
smaller it is now only about two and a
half points think about what this says
about in this particular case Georgia
voters that before the entire abortion
Fiasco started it was roughly 48.44 war
knock ahead
for a very brief moment Walker dropped
by like a point
and the race has now tightened to where
the difference between these two
candidates on the one hand incumbent
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock who
understands policy who understands
process who understands reality
is leading Herschel Walker by only 2.4
Walker doesn't understand anything
pulled out a fake badge claims to be a
police officer claims to be authorized
to work with police if something happens
which doesn't even mean anything
that claims to be pro-life with no
exceptions and yet paid for a woman's
abortion and then urged her to have a
second abortion which she did not do
and it is 2.4 points this says as much
about the Georgia electorate as it does
about the candidates and our voicemail
today has to do with exactly what I'm
talking about here